president trump continuing to
counterpunch nancy pelosi with a new
twitter taunt as the shutdown fight gets
personal after grounding her military
aircraft yesterday the president
slamming the house speaker for planning
to go on an overseas trip during the
government shutdown
and pelosi's office is responding by
accusing the white house of leaking
information about plans to fly
commercial
claiming it created a security risk that
caused the trip to be stopped
the white house is pushing back though
calling the charge quote
asinine and a flat out lie here's pelosi
earlier
he's very irresponsible on the part of
the president
we'll go again we'll go another time
this would have been my ninth trip do
you view this as retaliation for your
letter about the state of the union i
hope not
i don't think the president would be
that petty do you
sarah sanders firing back at pelosi over
the allegations
saying it's outrageous to claim the
president would put lives in jeopardy
meanwhile it's a tale of two shutdown
stunts for the media
watch as pelosi gets praised for trying
to delay the state of the union
while trump gets trashed for axing her
foreign trip
speaker pelosi flexing her
constitutional muscle
the president has responded in sort of a
childish way is the only way to describe
it
this bold power play by speaker pelosi
this is a sort of a classic example of
trump
kind of overreacting she's got a phd in
needling president trump
what has trump has done today tactically
inept strategically
nitwitted i mean this is political
genius the only phrase that comes to
mind is
nanny nanny boo-boo this is a case study
in media bias dana
this is a pretty good example it is a
pretty good example and um
when he was quiet for the day remember
and she got all that press for a whole
day
and the timing of the letter that your
trip has canceled coming a half an hour
before
they're to leave while they're on the
bus that was gold perfect
really gold and so and i mean if you
remember i did my sister test
right and she was like oh both of them
trump pelosi tired of it
that might be how a lot of people feel
but the media can't
can't do that i mean come on and then
also when when pelosi says
i don't think he would be that petty
it's like in the south when you say
bless their heart
a little bit like that bless your heart
greg yeah i think uh it could have been
trump it could have been worse i mean
trump cancelling the trip
is nice imagine if he'd allowed them to
get on the plane
and then he waited until they were in
the air
and then rerouted it so it flew in
circles around the us for like 11 hours
i don't know how long the truck was but
imagine if he let him fly in the air for
11 hours
right and then he goes okay let him land
in dc and then they come back they
landed dc they're all tired the ambien
is wearing off
they're getting that a few drinks they
get out and like nancy's like wow i
didn't know brussels had a white house
this is amazing so i think that he
actually did them a favor
jim acosta calling anyone childlike he's
these you know he's basically the
spokesperson for gerber baby food
i think the whole idea of calling each
other childish doesn't work anymore
it doesn't work anyway because everybody
everybody is a child now
we're a latin we we live in it we live
in a time where it's tit for tat so
that's okay
there's a really positive thing that's
going to happen i've said it yesterday
nancy handed him the golden key get out
of the state of the union
it's boring think of it as state of the
union
unplugged go back to its roots acoustic
acoustic an acoustic state of the union
the people say that you need to send a
letter then you have a rally
everybody wins and we stay here in new
york we don't have to take the train
and sit on the estella and listen to
that bubble of
bourgeois i don't even know what i said
it's all about travel anxiety i don't
want to go anywhere
all right this is this is one this is
newt gingrich talking about picking a
fight with the president and then you
can react
i don't know anybody who is more
predictable at counter punching you hit
donald trump
he picks up a large log slams you across
the head and says see
you made me irritated i mean she handed
him
a huge softball and said please knock it
out of the park
i guarantee you he's going to spend part
of every day from here on out
finding a way to cause her pain so the
president's plotting
in the oval office how else can i cause
pelosi pain
i think this delights you by the look on
your face jesse
uh but i think he's causing himself a
great deal of pain i mean i was just
looking at the polls today and it's
it's pretty clear all the polls indicate
that majorities blame the president for
what's going on and people don't like
the idea of shutdown don't think it's a
good idea to shut down the government
as a leverage point over building the
wall that we know mexico was going to
pay for
uh and you know to me they think you
know
we should get a deal we should be able
to reach a deal so you know to dana's
sister's point
it'd be nice that people sat down and
really thought
about this and really were able to
negotiate do you think one but no let me
finish but
here you have a situation where you had
republicans and democrats
make a deal mcconnell said here's a deal
it was the president who shut down the
government so now you have
vice president pence jared kushner
meeting with mitch mcconnell
they're trying to figure out some way to
help the president save face because
that's all this
is about and when he does something and
and
and i think that pelosi was very clear
and i think the state department
you know when they had to say you know
you can't go it's very clear
he did talk about the commercial
itinerary in a way that would have
endangered her life and the life of
everyone
on there but guess what in the
conservative media bubble
you get the kind of playground tit for
tat oh adam shift was on remember adam
schiff the one that the president
misspells his name with the tease it's
unbelievable that we are at this
juvenile level but i think the american
people
from the polls say enough of this
playground behavior it's not good it's
not good governance and it's not who we
are
well to that one i would say nancy
started it how's that
dr nicole sapphire juan says right now
the polls indicate that
everybody blames the president for the
shutdown if the president were to
cut a deal get the wall and reopen the
government would the american people
give him credit
for ending the shutdown and his base
would be very ecstatic about the wall
funding yes well of course his base
would be very happy but i'm sure that
the other side who never supports him
would come up with something else and he
would not get credit
there's more of an upside for the
president here right i do agree
i think that they really need to hone in
you know he has he has
compromised he's compromised on the cost
of the border wall he's gone from 21
billion down to 5.7
he's compromised on daca i mean these
are things that happen with this
campaign
you know he he's doing what he said in
his campaign he lowered corporate tax
he bombed isis he's bringing the troops
home this he has to do the wall he has
to do something here if he
forgoes the wall he's going to lose his
base and the republicans are really
going to suffer from this
now this tit for tat and it really is
nanny nanny boo boo but it's on both
sides
and it just is i mean pelosi's in hawaii
she comes back
and she says she's going to pull the
reins on the so too which okay
and then he cancels her trip i mean it
is a back and forth i want to see them
back in the white house
get some of their cronies get in the
oval office lock themselves in
and hash out a deal like there's no okay
let's shake hands and let's move on with
the day no you stay
in that office until you figure it out
because you have 800 000 people
not getting paid and when you're
praising the unemployment rate
how it keeps going down but now all of a
sudden we have employed individuals
not getting paid they're needing
gofundme accounts
they're having to file for unemployment
this isn't right so doc
i just want to point out that you just
said this is all about
the president's wanting to make a
political point it's not about border
security
by the american people whether you agree
with it or not he got elected
saying he was doing oh no no you're
wrong he got elected saying mexico
would pay for this walk no we're not
near that and so you have him well a lot
of people believe that the new nafta
deal against oh yeah
this is important you have now gary khan
the president's economic advice
federal reserve bank chair here in new
york saying what's going on right now
is slowing u.s economic growth the
president lets mrs trump fly last night
he won't let pelosi fly
it would be interesting to see an actual
specific plan by the democrats
that because now we have them on record
saying that they're for
enhanced border security they actually
say it now
even though their leaders said it was
immoral remember
walls were immoral and now now you have
them backtracking and saying but wait a
minute it's moral
so what i would like to i would be
really neat to see a plan a plan that
actually shows a border without a wall
i would like to see that because the
thing is if you want a deal you're going
to have to create money for enhanced
border right that's what would be
so the democrats have to come up with a
specific deal right
with this money that doesn't have any
wall
i would like to see that well do you
think that's possible i would like to no
no
one you believe that you could do it
without a wall then you should you
should write it down right now i want to
see you draw it out i don't i want to
see it's so hard
just awesome jesse was making fun of me
for going through the steps you know the
added funding in terms of security
personnel
the drones but no walls yeah you don't
your favorite radio host howard stern
said doesn't work
where'd you hear that from you there you
go at least we know one's listening to
yeah yeah all right only when he wants
to hear what he wants